all right so welcome everyone i'm felipe
gordon one of the uh organizers uh so
not all of us are here katie's here and
asia you will see a lot of this morning
she's giving the first talk um so uh i
don't know how many of you have been at
the assignments but uh uh uh the simon's
is a great place to interact and in
particular those boot camps have been
actually a great resources for me i've
learned a lot just watching the videos
or being here and this week with uh
since this semester we have a fairly
interdisciplinary program on geometric
methods of optimization and sampling
involving people from a variety of
communities um
including well optimization but
beyond you know pdes and pd's of course
have a lot of subfields that i'm outside
so i can just describe it as pds
calculus of variations optimal transport
is going to be featured prominently
algebraic methods so we've put together
a boot camp where hopefully everybody
can get up to to speed understand uh
what everybody's working on what the
terminology of different fields are
and i'm really glad to announce that all
the speakers have been really
playing uh uh really nicely uh this game
and you know we have uh worldwide
experts on on different domains and
they've agreed to actually give fairly
introductory talks so that we can really
get up to speed with each other uh so
the boot camp is uh you so you've
registered so you're probably familiar
with it but it's it's separated in five
days
on monday and five to five themes
mondays optimization
tuesday
tuesday is um
[Music]
sampling wednesday is optimal transport
thursdays pds and friday is algebraic
methods um so we're going to
talk today about optimization
and
so we have three talks uh
two morning talks uh that are
our crash course on uh optimization uh
by uh asia wilson and this afternoon
we'll have uh two more talks on uh
slightly more specialized topics that
are uh optimization on on curve spaces
in particular all right so uh without
further ado i would like to welcome asha
wilson from mit and she's going to give
the first uh of the first talk of this
bootcamp thank you
[Music]
okay hopefully all right perfect
i could be heard even though we're all
wearing math here so welcome everyone i
am going to give a two
part tutorial on optimization
and this is going to be the first
participant and it's going to primarily
cover optimization on euclidean spaces
and the topics i've chosen are situated
so that hopefully they blend well with
uh
nicolas's and schubert's talk on
optimization on romanian manifolds as
well as on more general spaces
so i had to shave some of the topics
obviously because optimization is a huge
huge area
but hopefully that'll set set the tone
for this
so in particular some of the core
concepts that i think will help get us
on the same page
are going to be uh that are going to be
covered in this first course are oracle
models and various function classes that
we often deal with in optimization
how do we generally establish
convergence of iterative algorithms
how do we deal with constraints if we
are optimizing over some complex set
and and some very very famous or
infinite lower bounds
okay with that i'm going to start with a
bit of notation so hopefully this is not
too heavy
i'm going to assume that we are working
on a finite real vector space
so uh think of rd whenever you see x
um and then i i can make this a little
bit more general so i'm gonna look at uh
it's dual space this is formed by the
the set of linear functionals on x but
we can think of it as a dual space as
again rd
um
so it's possible to introduce a
self-adjoint operator which i have this
notation be it's going to be a mapping
from this primal finite dimensional
space dual space
and it's going to help me define a norm
for all intensive purposes however i
think we'll think about b as just the
identity matrix so we're on euclidean
space
but a lot of what i'm saying can be
defined at this level of generality
um
i'll be referring to some some more
general norms particularly of these p
linear forms so think hessians and
higher order derivatives of functions
and so by if i write the norm of them
this is what i mean
um so be defined as this maximum over or
these unit directions
uh and final and finally uh i'll be
talking about uh or using the notation
of grad f for this this symbol f as the
a set of partial derivatives that's
fairly standard but uh
we'll see that uh in more general spaces
if we're talking about the gradient this
is not this is not what we mean
okay
so let's get started uh
one if you take an optimization course
we often formulate the problem or an
optimization problem as follows we would
like to minimize some function over some
set x or x prime
so here i'm noting x prime as our
feasible or constraint set and i'm
assuming it's compact and convex
and so by convexity i just simply mean
that the chord between any two points in
the set lies in the set
so hopefully people are familiar with
convexity it's a really really nice
notion and that is what will be uh what
we'll assume
also we'll assume that our constraint
set is is pretty nice and simple so i'll
give you some examples but uh
we'll we'll not be dealing as much with
more complicated constrained
optimization problems
okay so with that
um one last thing to note is i typically
these these feasible sets or these
constraint sets
are some sort of combination of a simple
basic set s which is going to be convex
and compact and some functional
constraints
that's the standard formulation of a
standard formulation of an optimization
problem over a convex domain
okay so the motivating example
will be uh well i'll have two it's going
to be first risk minimization problems
in statistics so these are pretty much
everywhere and the formulation is this
we assume that we receive samples from
some general sample space this is a nice
construct that we presuppose
i'm drawn from a
distribution and our goal is to optimize
some function over a decision vector we
can think of this vector typically as
like a set of parameters
um and so we can pose our risk
minimization problem as follows we would
like to minimize over x the expectation
with respect to my samples drawn of this
more general complicated function
this is normally decomposed into a loss
and some sort of regularizer over my set
but of course this is nice i think the
more
practical problem or the more prevailing
problem nowadays is empirical risk
minimization problems which are more or
less a proxy for these risk minimization
problems
so in this formulation
we have a finite set of data
that we assume again comes from some
distribution
and our goal is to generate a prediction
function which will be parameterized by
uh by x so this is the decision variable
and our goal will be then to minimize
some sort of loss function over that
prediction function and a label y coming
from our data
plus some sort of regularizer to
restrict uh the complica uh how
complicated our parameter can be
so we can think about the loss as our
data fitting term and the regularizer as
constraining it somehow
so those are the two motivating examples
that we'll be drawing from
um and hopefully if you haven't seen it
the the classic examples for our sub
examples in empirical risk minimization
are first of all regression
so here we have some sort of prediction
function y
um
y hat and our goal is to match some sort
of quadratic loss between our prediction
function and y
so these prediction functions can be
very general we can think of linear
functions as well as just a neural
network so some sort of composition of
linear maps and and some non-linearities
in classification we restrict y to take
on values negative one and one
and our goal is to predict the sign
or to predict y by the sign of our
prediction function
so typically we think of this true loss
or the true object we're after as this
zero one loss so it's it's got this cut
off here
um if we plot it
um and we typically it's it's hard to to
optimize and i'll we'll discuss why and
so um we typically minimize proxies uh
in its place
so some of the popular proxies are the
hinge loss
so this loss function is a maximum
over a one minus this inner product
between y are the a product between y
and the prediction function
and zero
and this is typically used for support
in the support vector machine
formulation there's also the logistic
loss this is a very popular loss that is
used in the context of machine learning
deep neural nets
and of course the infamous least squares
regression loss function
so this is the template to have in the
back your mind when we talk about
minimizing functions this is what we
want to work with
okay
so let's get into how do we actually
construct iterative algorithms that will
find solutions to our decision problems
in risk minimization and in empirical
risk minimization
our goal
again is to define or design an
algorithm to find the minimizing value
over our optimization problem
and we typically think of uh formulate
this in a
complexity theoretic framework whereby
we have some sort of iterative method
and an oracle and there's a game being
played here
so the game goes as follows the
algorithm will send a query point to the
oracle
and the oracle will then update its
information based on the query point
the oracle then sends back this
information vector to the algorithm
which the algorithm can then use to
update its state
and ask for another query point this is
the standard box formulation of
optimization
and so here are some examples of oracle
functional oracle models that are
typically assumed so in a zeroth order
oracle formulation the information being
given to the algorithm is the value at x
and the function value evaluated at x
in the first order oracle
we get in addition to that the gradient
second order of the hessian so we kind
of have this nice cascading
uh set of information oracles
now here are some examples of algorithms
which use this information
so
here i'm going to give you an example of
some first or some algorithms that are
designed using first order oracles and
some that are
giving or providing updates given second
order oracles
so each algorithm here takes on the form
of updating its state based on its
current state and some vector
gradient descent perhaps the most
widely known algorithm in optimization
simply updates uh chooses this vector
field or vk
as uh according to this minimization
problem involving the gradient and of
course we can think of this as
if we take x to be all of our d as just
choosing vk to be the negative gradient
direction
scaled by eta
and the two other examples we have the
second order oracle which is solving now
this quadratic problem
and again we can write this explicitly
when evaluated over all of our d as eta
times the hessian
of f at x k
inverse times
and this cubic regularization of
newton's method was an algorithm
proposed by polyacryl and i believe 2006
and this
optimizes or chooses this vector field
some optimization problem involving this
quadratic expansion of our function and
a
cubic term
we'll revisit this algorithm a little
bit later
okay
so having gone through the examples i'm
first going to discuss how we typically
or some organizing principles along
which we analyze convergence
so upper bounds for functions or for an
algorithm will depend on several things
it will depend on the geometry of the
set the function class we are optimizing
our function that we want to optimize
belongs to and the evaluation metric
that we're going to be using
um so i'm going to hop into this first
part of function classes first and
discuss some common function classes
that are
within the machine learning context
the first is this big distinction
between convexity or convex functions
and non-convex functions
and so here we have as our definition of
a convex function
that the cord between any two points on
the function lies above the curve
another way of formulating this is that
the epigraph
which i've defined here as the set xt
such that f of x is lower bounded by t
this is going to be a complex set
there's another way so so typically when
we're introducing notions of convexity
we leak to a first order notion
involving its gradients but we can also
make reference to convexity without
um introducing a gradient by
talking about the sub gradient so we can
say that a function is convex if the
subgradient set
of a function at a point x which is
defined here is essentially the
supporting hyperplanes at x is not empty
at all points
so uh classic examples if you have some
sort of non-smoothness in your curve
there are a lot of supporting
hyperplanes
and i think the the example that is
given um most often is the l1 norm so
i'll write it down here
actually am i blocking this board can
everyone see
okay good perfect
so if f is just
let's say the absolute value function
in one d
then the uh sub gradient of f at x
is given by negative one if x is less
than zero
negative 1 and 1 if x is equal to 0
and 1
otherwise
so that's that's a very classical
example the subgradients have a nice
calculus to them and they're always it's
a compact set and there's a lot of
things that you could say but it's it's
um a lot of the things we'll be doing
with gradients can be done with sub
gradients and so i wanted to introduce
this notion here
but moving on we have a first order
condition
that does involve gradients so we say
that a function is convex if it's
bregman divergence which i've given here
by this notation df of x y so the
spectrum divergence of x at y
this is uh not non-negative
so uh canonically the drawing is this so
we have this supporting hyperplane at y
and the value at x and this this gap
here is what's the breakthrough
divergence of
f x
and finally if our function is twice
differentiable we can define uh
convexity by the notion of its session
being positive semi-definite
and of course if it's twice
differentiable all these definitions are
equivalent
okay good to have convexity in the back
of our mind a little pedantic but i want
us all on the same page
okay so there's convexity other lower
bounds uh involve certain other notions
of of
uh
curves that's lower rounder functions so
perhaps the
most popular strong convexity
so this is the condition that our
bregman divergence is lower bounded not
just by zero but by a quadratic
with parameter mean
so we can think about the curve being
lower bounded by a quadratic
there are also kind of this family of
notions that that get
constantly called upon so weak strong
convexity is another notion
that is in use and it's a condition
along which we can actually get linear
rates of convergence for a lot of
iterative methods
so an example of a weekly strong convex
function or a weak strong strong convex
function is
a function of the form g composed with a
where
we have g as a strongly convex function
and a is some sort of matrix so
composition of a strongly convex
function and a linear map
and of course if you're weakly strong
come backs you're uh sorry if you're
strong come back strongly for x then
you're a weak strong x
there's also the restricted secant
property this is another property that
we can use to get linear convergence
and an example will be uh the same same
kind of formulation plus some linear
term
there's this uh very infinite pl
inequality i'm not going to attempt to
say the name here on video
but it's just simply that the norm of
the gradient is lower bounded by the
optimality gap scale by some constant mu
and so what's nice about the pl
inequality is you need not be convex in
fact
here's an example of a function that
satisfies the pl inequality that is
non-convex
and it looks like this uh if you
zoom out a bit so there's some sort of
curvature there but
uh
pl
the functions that satisfy the pl
inequality are are nice in some sense
because
uh all the minima are
are our global minima
and then last but not least there's this
quadratic growth condition that'll come
back later when we perhaps get into the
sampling portion of our tutorial
this uh has nice connections to telegram
inequality in more complicated spaces
but i think it's worth mentioning now so
there's this kind of cascading hierarchy
here of functions
um and i think the last thing that i'd
like to mention is that while everything
is uh
with this coefficient or two scaling
we can actually define these more
generally so we can we can kind of
lower down our function by this this was
called uniform convexity by this
polynomial
so there are functions that satisfy that
for example f of x is equal to x sub p
um or absolute value of x to the p and
then there's this also hierarchy
involving more general notions
i think that's useful to keep in the
back of your mind
okay and then of course there are these
classical upper bounds that we typically
assume for the function and its
derivatives so we typically assume some
sort of lipschitz continuity for
for some of the gradients and functions
um and so they're
they're classic examples most uh most
functions you'll ever deal with will
have
uh smooth gradients and smooth sessions
um if you are more compact space then
then you'll you'll also be lip shits
and what's really nice about the the
smooth or the lipschitz gradient
condition which we will call smoothness
um is that it is a quadratic upper bound
for our function so we can also write
this as the fact that the bregman
divergence is upper bounded by this
quadratic scaled by l
okay
so now i want to discuss convergence
having established those notions the
other thing we needed was uh how do we
measure optimality
um and i'm going to discuss three ways
that we tend to do that so suppose we uh
have introduced an algorithm that just
updates our state
um and we would like to ensure that
there exists a point that is epsilon
optimal
and this will mean uh roughly three
things
that is used in the literature there are
of course other notions of optimality we
can introduce
but um we we care about criterion that
certifies our function or our optimality
gap is less than or equal to epsilon
or that some sort of
pseudometrics that we can introduce
either in this primal space or the dual
space is also
upper bounded by epsilon so either we
want the distance between the iterate
and the optimal point to be small or
the distance between the gradient and
zero
to be small
um and so just if i've written here in
some generality because it can be
defined as such but the thing to have in
the backyard not your mind is just the
l2 norm
uh of xk minus x star and the dual norm
of the gradient
so these are typically the certificates
of optimality we are interested in
and
what the technique i'm going to describe
for how we certify this optimality is
that we just need some way of ensuring
that these quantities are strictly
dissipating along the trajectory of our
algorithm
so
this is where i think at least an
organizing principle that i'll be
introducing here and i think makes sense
to me is this idea of
viewing an algorithm or an iterative
algorithm in this context as a dispute
dynamical systems
so not all algorithms can be viewed as
such but a lot of the algorithms we'll
cover today can be so
i think this will be a very useful
notion and so
there is this idea in dynamical system
theory that we all have some scalar
valued function
and either we introduce it as something
we would like to be conserved this is
typically when we're referring to some
sort of physical system
like a lossless mechanical system or
something like that
um and there's also this notion this is
introduced by lyapunov
um where we would like this
this quantity to be dissipating along
his trajectory of our dispute dynamical
system
so the two criterion are this so that's
constant along the trajectory or it's
decreasing along the trajectory
and so i'm going to go through an
example but we can see that if you are
strictly decreasing along the trajectory
and this quantity is one of our
certificates of optimality then of
course we'll
achieve our goal of establishing epsilon
optimality so it's kind of just within
the framework
okay so here's an example um
it this is very popular within a lot of
optimization textbooks so it's just that
the optimality gap
is strictly dissipating along the
trajectory of gradient descent and here
i'm defining gradient ascent with its
step size restricted to be less than one
over l
uh and this is this happens when f
satisfies these two conditions so it's
convex
and uh it's uh
gradients are smooth
rather lipschitz
the convexity condition is just for the
strict property we'll see a lot of these
this will go through for for just uh lip
shits gradients or functions with
lipschitz gradients
and the proof is about three lines which
is why i'm going to actually
draw it out here
so essentially we write that the
difference between this this dissipating
quantity
um and if we write it out explicitly
it's just the difference in our function
gap
next we simply use this uh
this upper bound to uh upper bound that
function gap
then we use the algorithm and we plug
that in and we get two terms that can be
written in terms of the norm of the
gradient squared
and so this is where that step size
condition comes in
we know that if our step size is small
enough
then we can upper bound this entire
energy function or
a quantity by a negative term
and it will be strictly negative
unless xk is equal to x star and this is
owing to the convexity property
so here we have
the statement that this is going to
provide a certificate of optimality for
convex functions just this
just this three line
or four i guess
but of course there's been uh in the
last probably 30 40 maybe even a little
bit longer a lot of refinements
to these arguments a lot of times people
would introduce methods and then just
give an asymptotic guarantee and that
was that that's fine
but there's been a lot of work in the
optimization space of trying to give
more precise upper bounds and guarantees
of convergence
and so uh that isn't sufficient uh and
so typically i'm going to discuss two
broad strategies which we use to obtain
global guarantees non-asymptotic global
guarantees
the first is just trying to show some
sort of time dependent optimality
criterion is dissipating along the
trajectory of our algorithms
this is underlying most proofs of
iterative methods not all of course
um and and another technique that is
often uh found in non-convex
optimization
and uh stochastic convex
stochastic convex and non-convex
optimization are just is showing that
one of the two identities holds so we
want the sum of that optimality
criterion over the trajectory of our
algorithm to be upper bounded by some
constant times some term that can be
increasing but it is of k little o of k
so why does this give us a certificate
of optimality for some point
well it's because we can lower bound
both these terms by the length which is
actually k plus 1 but we can also lower
down that by k
times the minimal value that it takes
and so
if we just simply rearrange this
argument this gives us a rate of
convergence of little of one or alpha k
over k for that minimum value to keep
track of it so that's typically the
formulation of proof
in in the stochastic and non-convex
setting
okay
there are many many time dependent
dissipating quantities you can just
write down and in fact these are
non-unique and it's not often it's it's
hard to just start off with one and just
uh
prove that it works nevertheless i think
it's instructive to reveal which what
these quantities are for various
algorithms
um so
in the standard setting of smooth convex
optimization
there are uh
quantities involving both the optimality
gap and the distance um and there are
also
these uh quantities that will give us
this linear rate of convergence
and of course there are also very
similar quantities for for for newton's
method and cubic regularized newton's
method
um i'm going to just go through one it's
going to be three lines and very quick
uh just so you see and this is actually
a very non-standard way of formulating
this
um because i just wanted to highlight
the energy function so
the claim is that
this this quantity here is decreasing
for the gradient descent algorithm
uh with step size one over l or it could
be less than one over l when f is l
smooth and mu strongly conducts
so the main thrust of trying to
establish this works
is simply to write down that difference
uh in a really nice way so it's going to
be some sort of uh distance between our
two iterates
um and some scale distance between our
current or current iterate and the
optimal value
so we already established that if you
you are you have um
smooth gradients that the function value
here is going to be upper bounded by
negative one over two l times the number
of the gradient squared
and next i'm just going to pull out the
one over l
and then finally
this here is the uh
we can use the pl inequality that was
introduced before so this is actually i
can write this more generally that this
quantity is decreasing for l smooth
functions and functions which satisfy
the pl inequality with parameter mu
so this is going to be decreasing
this is a non-standard way of presenting
this proof
typically we just write down the
function value and do a lot of
calculations
uh but
but at least this reveals what what is
actually going on
okay so i'm going to talk about
constraints
there are tons of ways of dealing with
constraints and this is a one hour well
the first of a series so i have to trim
down what i'll be discussing
so i'm just going to be talking about
projections and proximal point methods
because i think those two will hopefully
be in line what will be going on today
i'm not going to discuss interior point
methods and a kind of a lot of other
ways of dealing with that are popular so
i apologize to to fans of these
techniques
maybe the next optimization tutorial
will will handle it
okay so
clearly if we have a a set um and we're
running an iterative algorithm there is
some chance that our iterate will fall
outside of our constraint set
and so we don't just want an optimal
point we want something we can certify
as within our constraints then and so a
very standard way of doing this is if
our set is somewhat easy
we can simply project the the use this
operator here to project the point onto
our set
so
this will be
this euclidean projection of course we
could define the projection operator in
different ways
but the projection satisfies really nice
properties when our sets are compact and
convex
so in particular the projection
satisfies this nice triangle kind of
inequality whereby we can say that if we
project our point onto the set
and consider another point in the set
then that original distance between them
is going to be lower bounded by the
point projected at the distance between
the points projected on the set and in
the projected point in the the point in
the set
so this nice triangle inequality
and what this implies is that
projections are not expansive
so when i project a point
things get closer together
this property alone will certify or is
all we need to to kind of say that if we
simply project to the point after we run
our iterative algorithm it will still
converge
so that's a nice way of dealing with it
if this is not too expensive
um so so if we we can write down the
projected gradient descent algorithm as
follows so again i find this vector
field that's just negative times
negative eight times the gradient
direction and then i simply project
my my future update onto the set and
that gives me
the update i would like
okay um the other point or the other
thing i wanted to point out is that
projection is really just this very
special case of a more general notion
called proximal point mappings or
proximal mappings
so
we could define the proximal mapping of
a function
as this minimization problem where we
simply minimize the function over some
ball
anchored at some point v
so if we take our function to be the
indicator of our convex compact set
then this proximal mapping is equivalent
to the projection operator
but this proximal mapping of course
there are other other definitions of f
we can use
in particular i think the one of the
most popular uh
proximal mappings that that's used is
the l1 for the l1 ball
so here we can actually write down
explicitly what this proximal mapping is
so we have uh
it's this shrinkage operator
where i'm i'm shrinking points to the
origin
so
i think maybe james stein just shrinking
points
okay
so proximal operators are firmly
non-expansive and satisfy a lot of very
similar properties that projection
operators do and it's because of this we
can
use or we can certify that when the
proximal operator is used it typically
has the same convergence properties as
as our original iterative method
so i'll give you an example suppose we
can decompose our function
our risk function into a loss plus a
regularizer
often what is done is we take a gradient
step with respect to our loss
and then we project uh or we use the
proximal mapping on our regularizer so
think the l1 ball
this is what is called ista
the ista algorithm and it's quite
popular dealing with with very simple
but um
easy to to project onto your constraints
and i think while just summarized rather
than go through another proof it's just
that the same quantities that dissipate
with respect to gradient descent
performed on the full function also
dissipate with respect to
this proximal gradient that's an
algorithm where i take a proc step over
the regularizer and i very rarely need
any assumptions on the regularizer other
than it is contacts
okay the final topic that i wanted to
discuss are is lower bounds
so
lower bounds uh there are some classical
ones that i think it's healthy to be
aware of and it definitely motivates the
the introduction of certain other
algorithms
so typically when we're introducing a
lower bound what we're interested in is
the minimum number of queries to an
oracle before an algorithm produces a
point that satisfies one of the
following epsilon optimality conditions
so
of all these algorithms within a class
what what
is the minimal number of queries it will
need to produce that point
and again lower bounds will depend a lot
on the geometry the function class which
evaluation metric will use and the
information the oracle provides to the
algorithm
so here's an explicit example of a lower
bound this is very classical it's found
in
uh it was introduced by nemourowski and
union in 1983 it's found in most complex
optimization textbooks
so the oracle is the first or oracle
order oracle so it's going to return the
function value in the gradient
the geometry i'm i'm kind of going to
not assume any complex constraint set
it's all of our d the function class is
a set of convex functions that have
smooth gradients
and the evaluation metrics are the
optimality gap in this this distance
the other additional constraint i'm
going to place on the algorithm is that
has to produce a point in the span of
the previous gradients
so with that construction a very nice
lower bound for for this for this class
of algorithms within this model
is
1 over k squared for the gap between the
iterate at xk and the optimal value
and actually if you look at the distance
we can certify that it is not
contracting
oh it's contracting but it's not
contracting at a polynomial right
okay so
what how do we establish lower bounds um
well a very popular method is to exhibit
a worst case function
so here the worst case function is this
really is a quadratic function
um it's a very structured quadratic
function so
there are twos on the diagonals and
negative ones on the off diagonals is
tridiagonal matrix
um and if you look at what the gradient
is of this quadratic function
we have this this interesting form so
it's l over 4 times ax minus this e1
direction
if you actually compute the span of all
the gradients this gives you the span of
all the unit directions or the the unit
direction seen so far if x naught is
zero and so what this is really saying
is that every iteration of a first order
method can only expand the search
space by at most one direction
so if your number of iterates is fewer
than the number of dimensions
then you have this resisting oracle here
whereby you cannot uh possibly find the
optimal point
there are some algebra you can kind of
quickly check you could actually write
down the optimal solution
the optimal function value and use that
to actually obtain this lower bound
so this is actually algebraic it's a
little bit harder to offer intuition as
to why this holds but it's a simple
construction found i think of nestorov's
04 book
but you can use a very nice argument to
minimize or to find the minimum or a
nice lower bound for the point um
xd so the d iterate
and it's scaling by one over d and
therefore conclude that the lower bound
is one over d squared
there's a
very similar quadratic gives you a lower
bound in
the strongly convex settings so here the
difference is uh
this function class i have now this
quadratic lower bound instead of zero i
have this quadratic lower balance so
it's strongly convex
and again i require the algorithm to
produce iterates in the span of the
previous gradients
and so now here
the lower bound now looks like
uh so if i define what's called the
condition number by l over mu so this is
going to be a quantity between 1 and
infinity uh the lower bound is on the
order of one over square root of the
condition number
e to the one over negative one over the
square root of condition number and the
same lower bound pretty much holds for
the iterates and the function value
so
what have we done so far we're kind of
nearing the end of this segment but so
far
we've illustrated this so if we have a
function that is upper bounded and lower
bounded by a quadratic then gradient
descent through that very simple
construction
will provide an upper bound of one over
the one minus one over the condition
number to the k
the lower bound however is one over the
square root of the condition number
and we can actually see that this square
root condition number difference can
make a big or can make a big difference
for poorly conditioned problems so here
we've written or we're drawing the level
sets of our function and gradient
distance simply just moves orthogonal to
those level sets at every iteration and
so if we have very oblong
level sets it's going to bounce back and
forth
and so for poorly conditioned problems
this can this can make a dramatic
difference
okay so with that i'm going to give us a
little bit of a break um
part two is going to get more into
more complex algorithms so i'm going to
talk about acceleration the algorithm
introduced to close this root condition
square root condition number gap
stochastic methods randomized methods
this will be variance reduction
stochastic sgd some very popular methods
for empirical risk minimization problems
um and mirror descent and i think mirror
descent is an algorithm which will
provide a really nice geometric
uh well has a very nice geometry
appended to it and will hopefully be a
nice kind of leading into what nikolas
is going to talk about with respect to
romanian manifolds
okay so
let's let's grab some coffee and i'll be
back soon